on the outskirts of mexico's capital
extreme drought conditions have forced
locals to travel long distances in
search of clean water
here in catepek it's mostly donkeys who
haul water up the steep hillsides
we use it to wash dishes and to drink
right now it's difficult to bring water
up here what i brought right now is for
the whole day
tomorrow i'll take another trip it's the
third year in a row that a long dry
spell has caused water shortages
in central mexico few places are
escaping the impact
even the ancient wetlands of sochimilco
rich in culture history
and biodiversity are under threat from
the extreme drought
which scientists say is affecting 85
percent of the country
scientists say climate change is
altering rain patterns in the region
the federal government says that drought
conditions in at least
seven states are considered extreme
a drier climate has also meant more
forest fires
mexico's national disaster management
agency says the 2021 fire season
has been the most destructive in recent
years
supplies strained authorities in mexico
city are urging
all residents to do more to conserve
this fundamental call is to limit water
consumption
in the face of this drought that
practically impacts the entire
north-central part of the country
take extra precautions against forest
fires
and as a drier hotter future looms
experts predict natural water
availability in the capital
to fall by almost a fifth by 2050.
manuel rapalo al jazeera
mexico city